we just arrived this relation here the
relation between the differential of the
speed of the rocket sled and the
differential of the mass of the rocket
and we want to ultimately get the speed
of the rocket so we have to do we have
to apply a technique called separation
of variables and then we want to
integrate what we're going to do is
first we're going to divide multiply by
DT so that falls away and we're left
with our DVR equals DM are you and we're
going to shuffle the M on to the other
side and we're left with DVR equals U is
a constant so that goes up front and
then we have R over m r that's an
equation that we can integrate now and
we can do that and the tricky bit is
that we need to take care of the
integration limits here we have V R and
actually these now all primes so we have
we are going from V naught that is our
initial condition here to we r prime of
equal V R of T and for the mass we have
M R prime equals M not actually not
quite am NOT it's to M naught because
the initial mass of this is the dry mass
and the fuel mass so that's two M naught
so this is near the initial mass and
then we go to M R prime equals F of V
are alright so let's do that we're going
to get VR minus
V nought equals u 1 over m integrator
gives us an LM so Ln and then we can
immediately do this here over to not and
well we ultimately want this so this is
an V R of T of course and then we get V
naught plus u Ln R over 2 m naught and
that is our equation so what does this
equation tell us M R the mass of the
rocket is less later on than it was
before
which means this term here is going to
be less than zero which means the
velocity is our initial velocity minus
something which means we have a decrease
in velocity which means my sled will
eventually come to a stop